such a great cast but your dad in this
movie played by Dustin Hoffman
greatest actors in American history and
and he plays this amazing character and
I was thinking what's it like to work
with Dustin Hoffman as an actor to be in
scenes with him well he first of all he
encourages you the whole performance
he's trying to make you the best you can
make he's looking at you he's worries
about everybody what is it about you you
worried about Ben he's just given advice
throughout the whole thing he's an
amazing guy in in the movie I think the
guy's unbelievable to watch so I hope
you love Dustin anity and and Stiller
know everybody in is really great I have
a funny story about Dustin we rehearsed
so we did that in a movie and we
rehearsed a lot mm-hmm to make sure it
was a lot of dialogue and a lot of stuff
so we needed to get that right and was
sitting in a Noah Baumbach apartment the
director yeah the director he wrote it
and directing that guy's unbelievable
man and a genius and anyways my a girl I
like in the movies were Rebecca Miller
and she's she's a very nice person very
good actress just a excellent in the
movie and she's married to Daniel
day-lewis
so Daniel day-lewis I know over the
years and he again I'm gonna compliment
another guy but he's just a great guy
he just fits us a guy a fantastic guy
and funny as hell and but anyways we're
rehearsin and Rebecca was there and we
finish or in the middle rehearsal and
Rebecca was done and Daniel day-lewis
comes by to get Rebecca and to pick her
up and he comes in the room and I'm like
Danny Boy what's up and I Ben Stiller's
lookin at me like you call me boy and I
was like
relax I got ya nice that must have
freaked out Stiller alone yeah I got in
Ben's head right how tight are they but
anyways so I'm talking to Daniel and
will laughing and having a good time and
Dustin's just sitting on the couch you
know looking away and stuff and we're
doing this whole thing we're having a
great time talking long goodbyes ba ba
ba
Daniel day and Rebecca they leave and
then I turn around and I say the dust
and I go oh what's up what's up with
that and he goes what and I go I you you
and Danny day-lewis got a little riff or
something something weird going on there
he goes no and I go why did you say hi
to him he goes when and I go just before
he goes that was
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you